so be is being blind I have included all
of this suspicion I'm just gonna get rid
of it now but you can see where I formed
it so important to do the logic to see
why the face now what I do in this thing
have a look at where you're headed
because thankfully this is a proof
question right now this is relevant to
end but that's very obscure and clearly
they're going to use this original pot
yeah okay so I'm kind of going to go
from here to here to here to here okay
I might even jump into here is my first
step I'm gonna go because this is a sum
of things that look like this so this
will be step two so this will be step
three now this is where I'm okay right
now this the first thing I'm going to do
is notice how the things are progressing
from left to right okay so you've got
two bits that are changing you've got
the NCR notation that's going up 0 2 4 6
and then you've got the powers which are
going down which is a kind of a problem
I've been doing some rotation right with
what the both to go up at the same time
I go down at the same time so which is
the easiest to change and the answer is
well hold on NCR notation because it
comes from Pascal's triangle you've got
this asymmetry right so you've got not
in shoes you're on one in an entry in of
course are the same it's symmetrical ok
so if I'm doing that that I can actually
reverse this whole order I can reverse
all of them so I'll make this one here
I'll be back in treated and this is
already known that's fine
this will be n minus 2 and so now you
can see that it's not a denominator but
this w at the bottom is matching my
power
is really good that's gonna be where I'm
headed okay because this matches this so
I'll just okay that's good remember this
is a show that's right so you've got to
make sure you don't skip any steps as
you go there this year is it the warm
water right it's deceptive yeah so
really what I should have this this is
webstar quick okay you both won't get
away with Skippy this line but I don't
think it's a very good idea beaver this
is a formal conclusion so I want to make
it super obvious that I understand where
the secret Asians growing a lot so I'm
gonna I'm gonna reverse the whole thing
okay start on this so this would be two
three gets me the pattern
whoops sorry for the third term but it's
okay now I'm ready to put it to
civilization okay so this is going to be
equal to right now what have we got
there have chosen cancer why not okay K
equals an Adu Stalin zero okay where do
I go up to right well because these are
doubling right things are doubly that's
why I go to no.2 you don't need to
justify that anymore because I've
written in that in a super clear way
it's clear enough I think that they're
in on two terms in this whole series
okay all right and then I and then I can
actually just rehearse what's going on
because this it's exactly the pattern
that I've got and then my path my power
here X is actually two
I don't have a general one yeah this is
for what does this represent again how
many alphabet - cool
twist I have a putt from the all right
now this is nice this is a good but I
haven't got peed yet I've only gone from
here to this right so how do I use this
over here
okay so firstly I'll I don't have it to
here so if I am bringing this here over
here should be here so I could say this
is equal to 1/2 times now again not only
do I have the division of here the to
the coefficient of there I also don't
have X I have to write so I'll now write
this 1 plus 2 and I'll say it like
where'd that come from for the answers
ok now so close right there now that's
at this step you can see the 1/2 is
there the 3 is there and then you look
at this now this is minus 1 to the M ok
now this is the great thing about having
a proof right you're like I know where I
have to end I just have to do why you do
have to justify why this is the case
might as well via it's equal to 1 what I
on earth would that always be the case
that the answer is because I only have
even powers like this is the switching
from the general solution to sign isn't
it right which always goes forward for
even values that's why we did it so I
can say that's 1/2 3 M plus 1 as this
equals 1/4 even barriers